[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir un chiffre inquiétant celui
des déplacés dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo ils sont quelques
000 à avoir fui les combats entre
l'armée régulière et les rebelles du M23
l'ONU qui se dit préoccupé reportage
dans une école qui accueille des
déplacés près de Goma la polémique au
Niger après l'attaque terroriste à Tamou
et la riposte de l'armée nigérienne sur
un site aurifère il y aurait des civils
parmi les personnes tuées lors de cette
riposte c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme
les ONG la société civile les autorités
nigériennes quant à elle réfute ses
accusations fera le point dans ce
journal
et à la fin de cette édition nous
recevons Bouchra Azzouz militante
féministe et réalisatrice elles viennent
nous parler de son documentaire sur les
femmes algériennes un film qui retrace
le parcours de quatre femmes 60 ans
après l'indépendance les détails dans un
instant
50 000 déplacés en 11 jours le chiffre
inquiet et il risque d'augmenter les
combats entre l'armée congolaise et les
rebelle du M23 ne baisse pas d'intensité
le tout sous fond de tension
diplomatique avec le Rwanda voisin
accusé par la République démocratique du
Congo d'armée les rebelles reportages
dans une école transformée en camp pour
les déplacer près de Goma il est signé
Justin kaboumba et Aurélie bazarra
kibangula
c'est une école transformée en site
d'accueil à une dizaine de kilomètres de
Goma le site de Bonga accueille près de
20 000 hommes femmes et enfants tous
sont venus se mettre à l'abri des tirs
et des bombardements sur chaque visage
la peur mais aussi la fatigue pas je
suis venu de Camember j'ai fui la guerre
entre le M23 et l'armée il
s'affrontaient dans notre village nous
avons entendu beaucoup de tirs et nous
avons fui vers rougarie mais la
situation s'est aggravée nous avons été
obligés de fuir à pied pour venir ici
ici les déplacer affirment que les
rebelles du M23 se rapprochent de la
route nationale 2 un axe stratégique qui
relie Goma et ruchourou dans l'urgence
cet agricultrice n'a rien emporté avec
elle
depuis que nous sommes arrivés ici nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé de la
nourriture les enfants tombent malades
parfois nous les amenons au centre de
santé mais à cause de la guerre ils
guérisse difficilement ils ne sont pas
en bonne santé nous dormons très mal
maintenant les humanitaires sur place se
disent
occupé par la poursuite des combats
chaque jour de nouvelles familles
arrivent sur le site pour se réfugier
les déplacés ni ce qu'ils vont manger la
situation est vraiment très précaire les
conditions de vie sont déplorables nous
avons déjà enterré 14 personnes et
d'autres déplacées viennent d'arriver
nous avons peur car nous allons
continuer à enterrer d'autres personnes
depuis la reprise des combats c'est une
véritable marée humaine qui déferle sur
Goma en une semaine près de 40 000
congolais se sont déplacés selon les
Nations Unies les autorités congolaises
mais aussi le groupe d'experts des
Nations Unies sur la RDC accuse le
Rwanda d'appuyer le M23 Kigali continue
à nier tout soutien ce groupe armé
et puis sachez que Vincent car réga
ambassade de Rwandais en poste à
Kinshasa a quitté lundi après-midi le
territoire congolais il avait 48 heures
pour le faire après la notification de
son expulsion par les autorités
congolaises preuves des tensions qui
persistent entre les deux pays voisins
Kinshasa continue d'accuser qui Galise
d'armer les rebelles du M23
on en vient à cette polémique au Niger
après l'attaque à Tamou d'un poste de
police fin octobre par des terroristes
l'armée nigérienne a lancé une riposte
aérienne tu as au moins 8 personnes sur
un site orifère depuis la société civile
et l'opposition accuse l'armée d'avoir
tué des civils ce que réfutent les
autorités mais les victimes ne sont
toujours pas identifiées la
correspondance à Niamey d'arol Girard
plusieurs membres de l'opposition
politique ce sont manifestés ces
derniers jours contre le gouvernement de
Mohamed Bazoum il réclame des réponses
claires l'attention est montée lorsque
le gouvernement a publié à 4 jours
d'intervalle seulement de communiquer
autour des événements de tamu la riposte
aérienne de l'armée nigérienne contre
ses assaillants du même jour lundi 24
octobre on aurait fait aucune victime
civile c'est ce qui est précisé dans le
premier communiqué du ministère de la
défense mais quelques jours plus tard la
présidence y apporte des précisions des
précisions qui stipulent qu'une enquête
a été lancée pour déterminer si oui ou
non les 24 blessés après cette riposte
aérienne sont tous terroristes ou pas
toujours selon le gouvernement les
assaillants étaient poursuivis sur terre
et dans les airs avant de se réfugier
dans des hangars sur le site orifer
clandestin près de la commune de Tamou
et c'est à ce moment-là qui a eu lieu
plus bombardements toujours selon les
autorités un bombardement qui est
intervenu sur un site qui est
fréquemment fréquenté par des civils
mais ringard dans lesquels ils ont
déposé le matériel volé
ce sont ces hangars qui ont été
bombardés pas plus que cela
et donc les personnes
qui sont mortes
sont ces personnes là
à coup sûr en tout cas
ces gens bien entendu qui sont venus
se réfugier dans le hangar
au moment où les frappes se faisaient le
gouvernement nigérien maintient donc ce
bombardement a fait 8 victimes toutes
terroristes une version très contestée
par une frange de l'opinion publique
mais pour l'instant aucun élément qui
prouverait un bilan plus lourd n'a été
révélé
l'Algérie est-elle de retour sur la
scène diplomatique c'est en tout cas le
souhait des autorités algériennes qui
organisent le 31ème sommet de la Ligue
arabe à Alger un sommet qui se tient
symboliquement à une date anniversaire
celui du déclenchement de la guerre
d'indépendance mais au-delà du symbole
les enjeux et les dossiers sont nombreux
le point avec Caroline lambolie
les dirigeants du monde arabe ont
continué à affluer ce mardi à Alger
parmi eux le président égyptien Abdel
Fatah
mais il y a plusieurs absents après des
mois de spéculation le roi du Maroc
Mohammed VI ne sera finalement pas
présent à l'approche du sommet le
secrétaire général adjoint de la Ligue
c'était montré confiance
la réunion préparatoire des ministres
des Affaires étrangères a montré qu'il y
avait un consensus autour de tous les
sujets qui ont été abordés certaines
questions ont suscité des tensions mais
elles ont été maîtrisées
au menu du sommet la crise alimentaire
déclenchée par la guerre en Ukraine les
pays du Maghreb et l'Egypte sont
particulièrement touchés une nouvelle
stratégie pour la sécurité alimentaire
doit être adoptée
les dirigeants aborderont aussi
l'impasse politique en Libye et la
situation au Soudan où les manifestants
réclament un état civil dans les rues
d'Alger les attentes sont faibles
nous espérons que les pays arabes se
mettront d'accord pour aller de l'avant
les dirigeants arabes ne tiennent pas
leurs promesses comme on dit la montagne
à cause d'une souris
alors que les relations de plusieurs
pays arabes avec la Russie continue de
froisser l'Occident le président
Vladimir Poutine a adressé une lettre au
sommet affirmant à la volonté de son
pays de développer sa coopération avec
la Ligue
et notre invité ce soir s'appelle
Bouchra Azz ouz militante féministe
réalisatrice et essayiste elle vient
nous parler de son film algérienne en
France l'héritage un documentaire qui
retrace le parcours de quatre femmes 60
ans après l'indépendance et qui nous
plonge au cœur de l'histoire
franco-algérienne quatre femmes nées ou
ayant grandi en France qui reviennent
chacune sur leur histoire familiale et
personnelle avant de rentrer dans le
cœur et le vif du sujet on va écouter
Djamila militant du FLN en banlieue
parisienne
on va descendre par terre
avec du sang avec déjà des morts parce
que taper sur la tête et taper ou il
pouvait
et la question que j'ai retenu quand il
demandait aux gens
tu sais nager
tu as tes papiers sur toi
parce que ça les arrangeait s'ils
avaient pas de papier c'est quand il
achetait dans la scène après on savait
pas qui était mort qui était vivant
j'ai une bonne étoile quand même une
idée
il y a une porte cochère qui s'est
ouverte une dame je me rappelle d'un
certain âge qui m'a attrapé par le bras
qui m'a fait rentrer dans ce hall en me
disant mais elle est pas sérieuse ta
mère te laisser te promener avec son
petit frère dans les bras
pas mon petit frère c'est mon fils m'a
dit alors je te lâche plus tu restes ici
et c'est ce qui m'a sauvé sinon j'aurais
tenu dans la scène avec mon fils
alors vous l'aurez compris Jamila
raconte son expérience de la
manifestation du 17 octobre 1961 ou des
milliers d'Algériens avaient été jetés
dans la scène bonsoir
bouchrazouz merci d'être avec nous pour
nous parler de ce documentaire très
touchant un documentaire sur je le
disais quatre femmes et c'est bien plus
que l'histoire du militantisme pour
l'indépendance de l'Algérie pour la
lutte contre le racisme ou la
reconnaissance d'une mémoire c'est la
réhabilitation des femmes et de leur
rôle souvent effacé aux minimiser dans
l'histoire
mais oui cette histoire elle échappa la
règle c'est que l'histoire elle est
écrite par les hommes par les vainqueurs
et les femmes sont souvent le point le
point aveugle de la grande Histoire or
quand on déploie quand on tire le fil de
cette histoire au féminin pluriel mais
en fait on se rend compte que il y a des
histoires qui n'ont pas été racontées et
qui manquent dans ce puzzle pour se
construire et construire sa mémoire
cette mémoire collective alors vous
c'est quatre femmes dont vous nous
raconter le parcours sont très
différentes comment les avez-vous choisi
et pourquoi pourquoi elle
alors la règle dans mes films c'est que
j'explore des de l'intime du personnel
de personnes de personnes de témoins que
je connais parce qu'il nourrissent une
réflexion qui est une réflexion
personnelle empirique qui croise un peu
la sociologie l'histoire les mouvements
sociaux et politiques de notre pays mais
qui partent toujours de mon observation
et donc ces femmes là sont des femmes
qui font partie de mon entourage que je
connais depuis très longtemps pour
lesquels j'ai une grande admiration et
pour lesquelles j'avais surtout
l'intuition que cette cette partie
visible de leur histoire que qui qui se
déployait qui arrivait à moi en fait
elle trouvait ses sources loin en
arrière dans cette histoire de la
colonisation puis de la guerre
d'indépendance et cette intuition que
j'avais finalement se confirme au
travers de ces portraits que je dresse
dans algérienne en France alors dans
justement ce documentaire se filme vous
abordez plusieurs sujets il y a
l'histoire de la guerre d'Algérie
évidemment qui est très présent mais il
y a aussi l'histoire de l'immigration la
volonté aussi de se faire accepter
d'avoir les mêmes droits donc il y a
beaucoup de thèmes qui sont abordés mais
il y a un thème qui revient tout le
temps qui est omniprésent c'est celui de
l'émancipation du combat des femmes
pourquoi vous avez choisi de traiter
finalement tous ces sujets à travers ce
prisme là celui de la femme et de son
combat encore une fois parce que c'est
une histoire qui n'est pas dite pourtant
nous en tant que femme issue de
l'immigration on a une conscience aiguë
de ce parcours héroïque de nos mères
puisque on les a vu cheminées tout au
long de leur vie et donc nous nous les
voyons comme des héroïnes ce qui n'est
pas le cas de la société parce que
simplement leurs histoires ne sont pas
restituées ne sont pas à raconter donc
il y avait une
nécessité de de ressortir en fait cette
histoire et de montrer cette héroïsme et
que finalement cet héritage et bien que
que nous avons a fait aussi de nous les
femmes que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
la société française et que ces
femmes-là sont aussi
en grande partie et elles ont mené des
luttes qui sont des luttes au service de
l'intérêt général et donc voilà c'était
important de restituer ces histoires
alors il y a beaucoup de choses à
raconter ce sur votre documentaire il
est il est très puissant je le disais
mais il y a une phrase qui est forte
celle de Djamila à la fin du film qui
dit aujourd'hui j'aide les femmes je ne
regarde pas leur nationalité je vois
juste que c'est une fois mais je vois la
femme que j'étais quand je les vois
quand je vois ces femmes qui ont besoin
d'aide et elle milite d'ailleurs encore
aujourd'hui pour aider ces femmes à 88
ans vous le dites dans votre
documentaire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est ça le message de votre
film finalement ben oui le message de ce
film c'est de dire que on part de cette
colonisation on part de cette guerre
d'indépendance mais finalement qu'est-ce
qu'elle a laissé cette histoire bien à
l'échelle de ces femmes qui ont été au
cœur de cette histoire elle a laissé des
valeurs qu'elles ont chevillées au corps
et ces valeurs là ce sont des valeurs
qui sont qui n'ont eu de cesse de les de
les habiter de les motiver de les
investir dans cette république qui est
fondée sur des valeurs universelles
d'égalité de liberté de fraternité de
justice sociale et c'est ça la guerre
d'indépendance de l'Algérie c'est pas
une guerre de haine c'est une guerre
pour des valeurs et des valeurs qui sont
les valeurs que nous offre la République
merci beaucoup Bouchra Azzouz merci
d'être venu nous parler de votre film
juste pour rappel il sera diffusé demain
soir sur France 2 dans l'émission
Infrarouge voilà pour ceux qui veulent
le voir un très beau film très puissant
sur sur des femmes pendant cette période
de la guerre d'Algérie merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de journal de l'Afrique
restez avec nous l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]